Despite the horrifying coronavirus numbers
I told you about earlier in the show, Donald
Trump is now holding daily rallies or even
multiple rallies each day.
At least one of these rallies has now been
specifically tied to more than 20 cases of
corona virus.
But that's a different story.
The real story here for us today is that at
his latest rallies, Donald Trump has become
even more authoritarian than we've seen him
be before, including vowing to lock up the
Bidens, which we will also discuss in a moment.
But these rallies are a true dystopian nightmare,
including Trump having the entire crowd boo
and jeer at the media.
The exact opposite of a president who respects
a free press.
But there's also a desperate and almost practical,
realistic element of Trump at these rallies.
Trump seems to be recognizing that he indeed
might lose to Joe Biden in just a little over
two weeks.
And Trump also seems to recognize or at least
admit that it would be very embarrassing for
him to lose because, as he says, Biden is
the worst candidate in history.
That's not true.
But the real reason it would be embarrassing
for Trump to lose is with all the bluster,
with all the narcissism and the attacks on
the left and on Joe Biden, there would be
an irony in Trump losing to a guy he claims
is a terrible opponent.
But there is one thing that Donald Trump has
now said in some form in terms of one state,
like, for example, Trump has previously said
in the last couple of weeks, he goes to North
Carolina and says, North Carolina, if you
don't vote for me, I'm never coming back to
North Carolina.
Iowa, if you don't vote for me, I'm never
coming back to Iowa.
But now Trump has taken it up a notch, which
is actually quite interesting.
Trump says if he loses to Joe Biden, he might
leave the country.
Check out this clip from his Macon, Georgia,
rally a few days ago.
I shouldn't jump because you know what?
Running against the worst candidate in the
history of presidential politics puts pressure
on me.
Could you imagine if I lose my whole life?
What am I going to do?
I'm going to say I lost to the worst candidate
in the history of politics.
I'm not going to feel so good.
I have to leave the country.
I don't know.
So this is fascinating for a few reasons.
First, it's clear Trump's primary feeling
will be embarrassment if he loses.
That's predictable, thanks to Trump's ego
and his narcissism.
Now, there are some of you who will say narcissists
like Trump can't feel shame.
He will just say that it was rigged.
Yes, of course he will say it.
But there is no doubt that privately at least,
it will be hugely embarrassing to Trump if
he loses to Joe Biden, which I would love
to see.
Second, there's the idea of hiding.
If he loses and this is becoming more and
more commonly mentioned indirectly, I've said
before in the immediate aftermath, if Donald
Trump does lose, he may well deny he lost,
claim it was rigged.
Be on Twitter 24/7, be doing but, you know,
press briefings all the time, accusing this,
that and the other person of cheating him
out of whatever.
But if it is eventually undeniable that Trump
lost, if Joe Biden is going to be the next
president of the United States, I wouldn't
be shocked to see Trump all but disappear,
just sort of evaporate into the ether.
And the idea of never going to states he loses
again and now of leaving the country is another
indicator.
Not literally.
I don't believe Trump will literally leave
the country.
But the underlying emotion of the idea is
there that Trump will just kind of disappear
and you won't hear from him again.
The reality is, I think the idea of a Trump
free United States would be so welcomed by
tens of millions at minimum, that the only
way Trump would really consider leaving the
United States leads us directly into layer
three of this conversation, which is the idea
of Donald Trump evading prosecution after
being president.
Now, by the way.
Is Trump says he's patriotic and his party
is patriotic.
Is there anything patriotic about saying you
will abandon your country if your democratically
removed?
But again, I don't think it is literal.
But think about what leaders leave their countries
after their reigns of terror are over.
It's authoritarian dictators fleeing arrest,
fleeing consequences.
This is something we've come to see many times
globally when authoritarians lose their grip
on power.
They go to a country without extradition to
live out the rest of their lives.
And if I must tell you, there are plenty of
countries that would no doubt love to make
use of a former American president who will
just trash talk the United States.
And Trump would easily find safe haven if
in plenty of places, if that's what he wanted
to do, he would become he would be welcomed
to become a sort of weaponized agent of social
discord, much like his presidency has been.
I know many of you are obviously thinking
about Russia.
This is bigger than Russia.
OK, now, the realization that I came to as
I was watching this farce take place in Macon,
Georgia, was if we don't want all of this
exact same stuff to happen again in four years,
we have to make sure that this guy is removed.
Now, all of these questions about Trump leaving
coming.
All this different stuff, we've got to remove
him now.
Talk about making America great again.
By the way, Trump leaving and ideally taking
those kids of his with him.
That would be one of the most powerful steps
Donald Trump could take to improve this country.
And if you're not yet convinced of that, let's
look at some more clips from a recent rally
that Donald Trump did.